[Music]
[Applause]
the name is called if maria is ten years
old I'm going to most have cerebral
palsy paula moderate caused by a
problem I had in the room when I
received the news that a son is in
a disability is very dumb maria and
was not supposed to walk was not only can I
say and that in a very uncertain future
stayed in stratham isora ​​neighborhood with
stopovers so where i know and i think
most also arrived before the show had
so many achievements because of all  the
environment that she has the friends the affection
that she has all that
environment that she always that nothing will
fail because there is a standard support there is
fundamental what I think gymnast speedboat wants now
jatene
I think it
is still the body of  casa can
teach you anywhere only with a
disability whether in portugal or in
any country of the european union because
this european can
I like it gives me luca had 6 d'water and i
want her to go now your difference
as one more di  difference as
with other children with absolute
counts it will be the same for her to do the
same thing even if
differently for her it is essential in pursuit
of activities with adapted surfing in
geography in the water occupational therapy
that she can fact against him all
the daughter's predictions
when I see most of them chatting in the
sea or in the pool toucou rio is and the father jo
tozzo the work we did together
was worth it